foreign
[Music]
we have just hit 2100
we are now facing very serious opponents
and for those who who have been
following the speedrun and kind of
watching it evolve we've basically hit a
rating where
opening theory has become Ultra
important so what you'll see in the last
couple of videos is that we spend a good
amount of the time we have during the
game and the time that we analyze
actually
focusing on the opening Theory and
trying to get it right because if you're
at 2100 standard on chess.com like at
this point you have to have a very well
put together opening repertoire in which
you basically know your main lines and
the entire premise of the speedrun is
that my explanations as well as the
analysis is made
to the level at which we're at so if
you're newer a newer chess player or if
you're a beginner hopefully you'll still
find helpful things within my
explanations but just realize that I'm
trying to level the explanations at the
rating range in which we're currently
are located so having
clarified that let's throw ourselves
into the pool and we probably will have
black we had white in our last Speed Run
game it was an elephant which our
opponent played the e65 variation was a
pretty quick game
let's see what the chess gods have in
store for us here there we go we have
white again against kazeo 2088 and as
usual we begin with one E4
let's see what our opponent bases us
with and we have a French which I think
believe it or not we have not faced yet
in this Speed Run don't quote me on that
I might be wrong obviously our response
is D4 and here
we are already at an early Crossroads
now the line that I have recommended in
previous speed runs is the advanced
French but not just a regular Advanced
French but rather the nimsovich
variation of the advanced French where
you go E5 blackplay C5 and then you
don't play the sort of automatic move C3
instead you actually develop your knight
it's a super counter-intuitive line if
you've never seen it before because you
know white voluntarily gives away uh the
pawn chain and allows C takes D4 and
there's like a deep positional
underpinning to the NIMS of its
variation that makes it I think a very
dangerous line uh for the unprepared
player but since this is a more opening
Theory minded speedrun I want to play
the line that I am most comfortable with
personally the line that I've played for
most of my life and that is the tarash
variation which is characterized by the
move Knight to D2 so if you know nothing
about the French
um then
you know very briefly white has a couple
of ways to meet the move D5 the most
natural of White's responses and the
most popular move is Knight to C3 that
leads to incredibly theoretical
variations and that's something we don't
want to touch with a 10 foot pole
there's also the exchange variation
which we also don't want to touch with a
10-foot pole I think the tarash is a
great line because it straddles the
bridge between not being too theoretical
uh but also
uh having that Venom which can allow you
to really crush a player who's not
incredibly well prepared and in response
to the tarash black has two main
continuations uh the the one that
appears more commonly in modern day
Grand Master chess is C5 and I'll talk a
little bit about it after the game the
sort of more traditional french-spirited
move is Knight to F6 and in response we
push E5 and we get kind of the advanced
French structure now the main line is
Bishop to D3 we bring our Bishop out to
the most natural Square black plays C5
and here in fact we do
play the move C3 and you shouldn't think
of this as an advanced variation this is
the pawn structure that you will find in
a lot of different French lines but the
advanced variation has very very
different piece configurations for both
sides so there's actually very little in
common uh between this line of the
tarash and the advanced French by which
I mean you know three E5 and in this
position white is that a further
Crossroads we have to defend the D4 upon
and we can do it in two main ways the
traditional move is to bring the Knight
out to E2 and there's a lot of
positional details that kind of stand
behind the reason why a certain move is
played or we choose one particular way
of defending the D4 Pawn but the move
that I have always played and I've
played this with great success the more
tactical line is Knight G to F3 so 10 to
15 years ago maybe even 20 years ago
this was still a newer move that was
catching French players off guard and
there was a period where uh even the
strongest GMS and noted French experts
were struggling tremendously against the
move Knight gf3 but now this is a very
well-known line it's still less popular
than Knight to E2 but in my opinion it's
more dangerous and it's easier to learn
and to play for the uh sort of
intermediate player so black responds
with one of the many possible
continuations just kind of a regular
developing move Bishop to E7 and we do
the same we castle kingside and here
black is at a further Crossroads there
is a super tactical line where black
plays G5 I'm really hoping that we face
that line in this game because that will
allow me to illustrate a lot of the
juicy ideas that white has in this
variation of the tarash but uh French
players who aren't too familiar with the
Knight gf3 variation often resort to the
more natural continuation which is just
the castle King side and in that
position white has sort of a small but
very stable advantage and White's play
in that line is pretty intuitive and
rather unremarkable
um so our opponent is taking little bit
of time don't you know it misinterpret
my words the tarash is still like a very
very theoretical line and you still have
to know a lot of theory if you want to
play this line successfully for white
but you still can't compare the amount
of theory in the tarash to the amount of
theory in uh three Knight C3 which I
would never recommend even to like an
advanced player because the time
investment that you have to put in uh to
play Knight C3 successfully I just think
is not uh realistic for you know most
people with like a job and and a family
I think Knight D2 again kind of strikes
that balance it gives you a serious
chance to fight for the advantage
without being like ridiculously
theoretical there's a lot to know but
you can definitely learn this
um and you can play the Torres very
successfully
so we get back to this position and
we're facing the move A5 which is yet
another of Black's uh kind of top rate
continuations this move
uh is is very very common in this line
and it's a more positional way for for
black to to treat this line black is
kind of grabbing space on the queen side
black is also preventing well Knight B3
was impossible anyway because of C4
Black's main idea is to drive this Pawn
down to A4 and make it very difficult
for white to reshuffle his pieces on the
queen side right that pawn on A4 uh
really clamps down on some key queen
side squares and it makes us makes it
hard for us to play B3 it covers the B3
square and often black accompanies the
move A5 with uh the follow of Queen to
B6 which exerts even more pressure on
the uh D4 Pawn so there's there's many
ways that we could meet the move A5 but
the most most natural one and the one
that I've played uh for most of my life
is just to play A4 and and to freeze the
A5 Pawn in its tracks
um I think this is a very unpleasant
move for most French players because
we're preventing black from achieving uh
their main aim you know that is to drive
the pawn to A4
so once again we just shut all that
garbage down we play A4 I've had this
position uh in in numerous
over-the-board games
and here black plays Pawn takes D4 so
our opponent displays a good knowledge
of opening Fury the point of this
sequence is that by provoking us into
playing A4 black has created an outpost
for his Knight or his Bishop but
typically his Knight on B4 and we're
probably going to see our opponent play
the move Knights before and I think one
thing that has to happen as you climb
the raiding ladder is you have to have a
more nuanced uh positional perspective
on whatever situation you're in so I
think a newer player would see the B4
square and say well this is really
unpleasant right black and play 90
before and attack our Bishop and that's
a huge Outpost for the night but the
Outpost on B4 is just one of many many
components in this super rich position
some of those components favor black but
a lot of those components actually favor
white so for one thing we have the
equivalent outpost on B5 and it's true
that it is all a lot harder for us to
get a knight to B5 because for us to get
a knight to B5 we would have to burn
three Tempi and you actually do see
white playing the move Knight B1
followed by Knight C3 and sometimes
Knight B5 in this line and the reason
that you have these Tempe to burn is
that the center is closed and as I've
clarified on many occasions when the
center is closed you typically have more
time to do what it is that you want to
do whatever it is like any maneuver any
plan you have more time to achieve it
because there's kind of less going on
and as long as you can keep your Center
defended you've got quite a bit more
time than you would with a wide open
Center but I don't really want to play
Knight B1 I don't want to commit to a
particular uh mode of play I want to
wait for black to put his cards on the
table and in these positions white has a
why does quite a few moves that are
non-committal but that improve your
position and that set ourselves up for
success in the event that the Center
opens up and if you're a more habitual
French player with either side you
should know that there is one idea that
you should always be prepared for like
when we look at this position
we've talked about ways in which black
can attack the D4 upon and in reality
there is only one such way black and
play Queen to B6 but you can also attack
this Pawn chain from the other side and
it's a lot more common across all French
lines for black to play the move F6 this
opens up the center it opens up the
f-file and whatever we do we need to be
prepared in the event that black decides
to play F6 and so a very very good way
for us to do that is just to situate The
Rook on E1 might seem like a pointless
move because we're putting the Rook on a
closed file but in light of my
explanation you should begin to
understand how it helps us prepare
against F6 we're discouraging that move
quite strongly because we take on F6 and
not only does The Rook then find itself
on an open file but the pawn on E6 is
right in its crosshairs and uh if after
F6 e takes F6 black is forced to take
back with the Knight then black weakens
his grip on the E5 square and we can use
that juicy juicy Square as a big Outpost
for our Knight
so black plays night before our opponent
obviously does not resist the temptation
and forces us to decide on a spot for
our Bishop so there's a couple of ways
that we could approach this we could
stick our Bishop on the equivalent
outpost on B5 but I don't like like that
move as much because I like to play this
line in a very tactical attacking Manner
and so I really like the placement of
this bishop on the B1 H7 diagonal why do
I say that because well the bishop is
targeting the H7 Pawn so there's Greek
gift sacrifices that could happen once
we bring more pieces to the king side
that Bishop is going to be a an
invaluable asset as we transition our
attention from the center to the king
side and so therefore the move that I
like is Bishop back to B1 nothing wrong
with making a retreating move the bishop
is just as effective here as it was on
D3 it's still aiming at H7 and one
additional idea that this move makes
possible for later is Rook A1 to A3 we
could actually lift The Rook right under
the knight's nose because in playing
Knight before black has cut his control
over the A3 Square so in a future where
let's say we move the Knight away from
F3 we could play Rook A3 and quickly
involve The Rook into the attack so if
you're looking at this from the
perspective of space it may seem like
black is doing fantastic again like he's
played night before and he's pushed our
Bishop to the back rank but that's why
Bishops exist they're super long range
pieces and I'm telling you we're only a
couple of moves away from being able to
launch a mating attack so unless black
handles this very very accurately
um I feel like we are only a couple of
moves away from smashing through on the
king's side which could be hard to
conceptualize but hopefully the course
of the game if it goes in our favor will
allow me to demonstrate that okay so our
opponent continues to think
our opponent has a couple of issues that
uh that they still have to solve
obviously there's this famous French
Bishop on C8 which still doesn't have a
home most people here I think have the
inclination to play B6 and try to deploy
the bishop via A6
but even if black does all that that
Bishop on A6 is still kind of out of the
action okay instead our opponent plays
Knight to B8 which is a regrouping that
I've seen before I guess our opponent is
heading for C6 with the Knight and
probably wants to leave the D7 Square
open for the bishop but this is where we
start assembling our pieces not into
like full attacking position but we
basically assemble our pieces in the
general vicinity of the king side and as
crazy as it may seem for me to say this
we're already preparing for a mating
attack so there's one particular
maneuver that you have to know in order
to play this position successfully and
most people in the chat are are
indicating this move which is pretty
impressive to me and that is the move
Knight F1 if you play the real Lopez
really if you're a one E4 player you
should be familiar with this maneuver
because it's it's it's virtually
Universal across uh a large amount of
different openings the Ray Lopez is one
of them and this opening the tarash
French is another it is incredibly
common for white to maneuver the Knight
over to G3 now why do we do that what
exactly is the Knight doing on G3 well
well the reasoning is pretty simple
first of all we're kind of unclogging
the pipes a little bit
the Knight on D2 is in the way of
essentially all of our pieces that's in
the way of the queen it's in the way of
the dark squared Bishop on G3 it's
completely out of the way of the other
minor pieces but the Knight can itself
be used as a major attacking weapon we
can jump from G3 over to H5 and you can
already see that you know certain
sacrifices are starting to loom in the
air like Knight takes G7 could be
possible if black plays G6 in response
we could stick the Knight on F6 and
sometimes that move is very strong even
if it sacrifices the pawn uh because it
gives us a complete and total dark
Square domination so already in this
position we have multiple ways that we
can continue the attack The Rook A3 move
that I had mentioned earlier is a viable
candidate move we could set that Rook up
in position so that when the knights
move out of the way it can jump into G3
but another very typical idea that
you'll see in a lot of like French books
and a lot of attacking manuals is the
move h2h4 and if this move works out
successfully then after the game I can
show you countless examples of this move
leading to a decisive attack again
across many different openings like
that's the beauty of the attack that uh
we're about to unroll I I really feel
like all of these moves are essentially
Universal so your eyes shouldn't glaze
over just because you know you're not a
1e4 player or you don't face the French
a lot you know these are important ideas
for you to uh for you to conceptualize
because they form the underpinning of
successful attacking chess now what the
heck is the point of H4 and it's not
what you might think of course we can
advance this pawn two squares to H6 but
that would actually serve to close the
king side up that is the last thing that
we want because it would allow black to
play G6 and then it will be very very
hard to unclog uh the kind of reverse
Triangle Pawn formation that black would
have set up
a much more common follow-up to H4 uh is
of course Knight F3 to G5 so we're
creating a stronghold for the Knight to
jump to G5 and once the Knight jumps to
G5 the diagonal now opens up for the
queen to LEAP into H5 so you can see how
quickly the pieces start coming into
position and there's often a point at
which you have to sacrifice something
like for example if we're allowed to
play Knight G5 and black responds with
H6
as you should already understand the
point isn't then just to jump back to H3
it's often to leave the Knight on G5 so
that if black takes it with the H Pawn
the H file opens up so a great follow-up
would be for instance Queen Z1 to H5 or
even Queen Z1 to G4 targeting the G7
pawn and x-raying the King now all of
this is great you might be looking at
this and saying well I get it we want to
go Knight G5 but what happens if black
takes the pawn on H4 and I will be
honest I haven't decided yet on a
specific response to that move but this
is something I'll address in a little
bit more depth after the game assuming
our opponent doesn't take that pawn
but there's a couple of important things
to understand before we even address
like the actual point of the sacrifice
and the first is that in these types of
middle games a single Pawn almost never
decides the outcome of the game almost
all of the pieces are still on the board
and so sacking in h-man is not something
that you should think of in the same
category as a queen sacrifice or like a
peace sacrifice right you should
distinguish in your head Pawn sacrifices
from peace sacrifices and I know that
sounds very banal but a lot of players
they lump that into the same category
like they think of H4 as a huge
commitment and if the attack doesn't
work out we lose and on the vast
majority of levels that's absolutely not
the case so one very simple thing that
we could do after Bishop takes H4 would
have would have just been to take the
bishop and claim that we have the bishop
pair and dark Square control so it's
really not such a big investment or
commitment to where you have to have a
clear understanding of what you're doing
if black takes the punt we'll talk about
that more after the game because black
has taken the game in a completely
different direction he's played F6 which
I think is a pretty adequate response to
H4 black tries to open up the center and
make it harder for us to concentrate our
forces on the king side well we don't
have too much of a choice here
uh we don't want to allow black to be
the one to take on E5 we should do it
from a position of strength so let's
start by playing e takes F6 it would be
great if we could play Queen Z1 to H5
here unfortunately that is illegal and
now we reach a critical moment here we
have to be very concrete and very
accurate because
we've got a weakness on D4 and we have
to keep that pawn in mind that's not
just any pawn if we give that pawn up
and black takes it with the bishop then
the F2 Pawn will be in the crosshairs of
the rook and the bishop as well so
Knight G5 might come to mind as a very
tempting move but in response to Knight
G5 black will probably go H6 and if we
just blindly throw our pieces onto the
king side we might very well end up uh
at a dead end because black will take on
D4 and generate pretty massive counter
play based on an attack on F2 so if we
do play Knight G5 we actually have to
calculate some variations there some of
you are pointing out Knight G5 H6 and
then Knight takes E6 but then black
plays Bishop takes C6 Rook takes C6 and
Bishop takes D4 and again it appears
that white is at a dead end because
black has major major pressure on F2
then H4 is also going to be hanging that
doesn't seem to be really in the spirit
of the line so I'm going to take a
little moment here and think about our
candidate moves what's interesting is
that we haven't really made any tactical
commitments right we haven't committed
to playing sacrificially or even playing
tactically we could take this in a
positional Direction because if we think
about the move F6 in sort of a
positional framework the the main
drawback of this move is that it creates
a massive hole on E5 and this hole could
be used later on in the game as an
outpost for our Knight so you might say
well what are we waiting for let's go 95
but if you go 95 too soon this goes back
to something that we discussed in an
earlier game which is that you don't
want to occupy a weak square with a pawn
you typically want to occupy it with a
piece and after Knight takes E5 we would
have to recapture with the pawn and we
would also give up H4 so you might say
well how do we prepare the move 95 Let's
Play Bishop F4 and that would be a
totally viable move but I think a more
challenging move for black would
actually be Bishop C1 to G5 this is a
more active way to try to remove one of
Black's critical Defenders on the E5
Square
um and this is a typical concept so
notice that we played H4 with a tactical
aim in mind we wanted to check May black
with Knight G5 but we're actually using
that move for positional purposes and
this is the flexibility that I talk
about really often which is necessary if
you want to thrive at a high level you
can't get fixated on one particular goal
okay black did something unexpected so
we change our frame of thinking and now
we're playing very positionally for
control over the E5 Square what is black
likely to do here well if blackplay's
Bishop takes G5 I actually think we
could have some really really cool
tactics there based on a Greek gift
sacrifice with Bishop takes H7 believe
it or not
and we'll explore that after the game
because I don't think black is going to
take our Bishop but it's essentially
functions like a regular Greek gift
Bishop G5 Bishop H7 King H7 we recapture
on G5 with check and after King G8 Our
Queen drives into H5 and I feel like the
attack is Unstoppable much like it is in
like a regular Greek gift sacrifice
so what happens if like doesn't take on
G5 well the move I'm expecting is H6 I
think this is going to be the Instinct
of most like 2 000 players and then of
course we play Bishop takes Bishop black
will probably recapture with the queen
which I think is the most natural way of
recapturing and then I think would be a
great time to increase our control over
the E5 Square by applying The Rook lift
that I had talked about earlier like
Rook a through rookie 3. and again when
I had mentioned this Rook lifts many
moves ago I mentioned it in a tactical
context I mentioned it in the context of
trying to get the Rook let's say to the
G file and again we're repurposing a
tactical idea into a positional idea
we're using the Rook lift to increase
our control over this key Central Square
on E5 and we're going to try to like
strangle black positionally rather than
Checkmate him tactically if H6 happens
um now you might hear all of that and
say okay this makes sense but haven't we
seriously weakened our King side with H4
and H4 is is far from a serious
weakening of the king side it really
isn't a big deal that we pushed the
h-bond because we still have the kind of
the core of our King Side Pawn formation
and our King is still perfectly safe
Queen C7 okay that's a decent move I
think by our opponent which doesn't seem
to do all that much I guess it unpins
the bishop but it's not like the bishop
has all that much Mobility to begin with
and I think there's no need for us to to
take on F6 and allow Black's Rook to
jump into a pretty good Square on F6 I
think we should proceed with our plan as
if black didn't do anything
and we already know what a great way to
improve our position is I think we
should play Rook A3
and we start playing this kind of
General waiting game where both of us
are trying to improve our position and
eventually things are going to clarify
like something is going to happen very
very soon because the tension has
reached a peak but for the time being we
can just chill because everything is
nicely defended one annoying aspect of
this position is that we can't put our
Queen on T3 or C2 that would be
incredible that would be sexy that would
be like the best battery of all time so
we have to give some credit to the
placement of this night on B4 it is
restricting uh the mobility of our Queen
but we can do without it and our Bishop
is still an excellent piece because it's
still creating constant headaches for
black on the H7 Square
The Rook A3 lifting The Rook up to E3
and you shouldn't think of that move as
increasing the pressure on the pawn
because the pawn on E6 is actually
pretty well defended by the bishop so
unless we attack it with a minor piece
that pawn is not going to be winnable
instead we're increasing our control
over that stronghold on E5 and one day
we hope to occupy that square with the
Knight we don't know when that day will
arrive we don't know if that's
ultimately going to be what wins us the
game but by doubling Rooks on the e-file
we're actually making it very difficult
for black to breathe so already black is
I think starting to run out of helpful
moves
when that happens usually people try to
force things so I'm expecting H6
and in response to H6 we probably will
take the bishop on F6
um another thing that you should be
aware of is that if we play Bishop takes
Bishop we should not be afraid of black
taking back with a pawn because that
fixes one problem right of the E5 score
but it creates like 50 others if
Blacklist G takes F6 the king is going
to be wide open and the pod on H6 is
going to be a Sitting Duck and we can
simply Target it by playing Queen to D2
in that position
and you should always remember the
possibility of Leaping into H5 with your
knight right if black ever brings the
king up to G7 that knight from G3 can
jump into H5 and force the King right
back to G8 okay so obviously black plays
rookie eight we play rookie three in the
kind of waiting game continues this is
where things are about to get very
exciting so Le Mama asks what if black
plays E5 I haven't calculated this move
but I'll bet you a silver dollar that E5
is never going to work in this position
how do I know that because Black's
position is so riddled with holes and so
passive that opening up the center like
that just isn't going to work in
response to E5 we can for instance take
on F6
and after Rook takes F6 Pawn takes C5 we
literally have more Defenders on the E5
Square than black as attacker so it just
loses a pawn so you should I mean E5 is
a legitimate idea in the French but in
this particular situation we're so much
better prepared for the center to be
open that this isn't something that
that's even on my radar Queen D6
so to our opponent's credit he is sort
of maintaining his composure which means
we need to turn the pressure dial
up a little bit more now we can make
moves belonging to two categories here
we can continue playing like General
Russian Schoolboy moves and that would
involve you know Queen to D2 or even a
move like B3 you'll sometimes see GMS
maybe Shore up the A4 Pawn kind of pass
the ball back to black but I feel
personally that the time has come for us
to take more concrete more decisive
action because we've essentially
improved our position to the maximum and
there is one move uh there is one asset
that we haven't exploited yet which is
of course the knight jump to H5 and this
is what we just talked about I think
this would be a great opportunity for us
to throw that move in why are we playing
Knight H5 here because you might look at
this and say well I don't see what this
threatens well this doesn't threaten
anything tactical we're not threatening
to win a piece but what we are
threatening to do is completely ruin
Black's Pawn cover by taking this bishop
and forcing black to take back with a
pawn in particular this is bad for black
because then the bishop can also jump
into H6 and the dark squares are on
Black's King are going to be completely
indefensible so that's like an
unthinkable option for black we're
essentially forcing black to take on G5
and we already know that this trade
particularly in that version is super
favorable for us
a because the E5 Square will then be
under our complete control and B because
tactically after Bishop takes G5 we
could consider either a Greek gift
sacrifice on jifa on H7 which honestly
is a little bit less appealing to me
because the H5 score is occupied by the
Knight or in that situation we could
have just recaptured with the pawn and
then stuck a knight on E5 King h8 our
opponent calls our Bluff isn't afraid of
Knight takes F6 and actually prepares
for that eventuality by opening up the
G8 Square for The Rook so he's sort of
preemptively tucking the king away uh so
that Knight takes F6 comes with a little
bit less Force which means that we
should kind of consider changing our
plans I no longer think Knight takes F6
is the best way to squeeze the most out
of the position because after GF it's
actually not clear who that
transformation favors because once black
puts a rook on G8 guess what like R king
isn't the safest piece either in Black
it generates some counter play so now I
think would be a good time to ask
ourselves like do we want to do
something tactical do we want to try to
Checkmate black on the king side or do
we want to continue improving our
position
let me think about this for just a
second because this is an important
moment I have an idea that I think is a
good move
but I have to double check yeah I'm
pretty sure that the move I have in mind
actually might win the game so remember
that I mentioned earlier that when we
have a weak Square we don't want to
occupy it with a pawn well there's an
asterisk and a caveat to that right
because everything I say of that form
is not a rule right it's it's a general
guideline and the situation on the board
could change your approach to that
guideline I think
that the best move here and the best way
to squeeze the most out of the position
is in fact to play Knight to E5 now this
is based on both a positional and
tactical observation tactically it's
easy to observe that if black takes with
the Knight yeah we take pack with the
pawn but this is a fork this Forks the
queen and Bishop and wins a minor piece
but what about Bishop takes C5 well in
that case we take back with the pawn and
I didn't calculate any further than that
I calculated up to that position and I
concluded that the presence of two minor
pieces on perfect attacking positions
the possibility of us completing our
Rook lift to G3
and the ease with which we can involve
Our Queen in the attack basically means
that black situation on the king side is
going to be completely hopeless and I
already see like two or three different
types of sacrifices that just end the
game straight away so for instance after
Bishop E5 de let's say black drops the
queen back to C7 a very easy sacrifice
would be Knight takes G7 replacing the
Knight with the queen and that's a
position which should kind of
intuitively
be clear to you and it doesn't even have
to be clear to you because we're going
to reach it in the game
our opponent is kind of so focused on
winning the battle of the E5 square that
I think he's he's kind of missed the
forest for the trees right now he thinks
okay finally I can breathe a sigh of
relief the Rooks are kind of pointlessly
located on the e-file and now it's I
think Dawning on him that we once again
switch our attention from the center to
the king side and we again switch from
positional thinking to direct tactical
thinking to Checkmate mode
and we're only 22 moves in it feels like
we've been playing forever but you know
we've barely exited the opening Queen to
C5 and now it's time for us to think
concretely to calculate and try to find
the fastest path to checkmate so the
simplest pattern here is I think to play
Knight takes G7 the idea is twofold
first of all we're shattering the pawn
protection of Black's King which will
make it easier to deliver Checkmate but
second of all we're forcibly removing
the knight from H5 so that the queen can
take the knight's place and queen H5 in
that resulting position just looks
absolutely crushing I really think that
we don't need to calculate that line any
further if that's not crushing then I
quit chest like that has to be crushing
maybe we have a nicer Checkmate maybe
there is a more precise way to win the
game but in the context of a rapid game
you shouldn't get bogged down with
trying to find the perfect solution once
you see something that looks really
really juicy and relatively
non-committal because we're only sacking
a minor piece right this isn't like a
queen sack you can safely go for it
so no I'm I'm like literally 100 million
percent sure that this is
Unstoppable Checkmate black has to take
the Knight otherwise we play Queen H5
anyway and this is resignable so the
attack essentially ends before it begins
okay now
I know that they're they're you know
where a lot of Concepts in this game
that I touched on either briefly or
superficially and that's because you
know we've never faced the French before
and I've never played the Taurus before
which is why like I I couldn't talk
about everything but hopefully the
general course of the game made sense to
you and the reasoning behind almost
every move
the king is in shambles and it's
instructive to see how like all of flax
pieces are kind of stuck in no man's
land
like the B4 Square was once significant
but now is completely pointless like
nothing's happening on the queen side
and of course now we should take a
moment and realize that Bishop F6 check
I think would be a very serious
inaccuracy and a move that would appeal
to a lot of beginners and the reason is
because blackheads sacked The Exchange
on F6 and that's the last thing that we
want the last thing we want is the
situation in which we're suddenly out of
attackers and Black's King is close to
escaping via the center and in general
when you're trying to Checkmate the King
on one side of the board you should keep
one eye open for like the king's
possible Escape Routes because a lot of
attacks have been uh refuted uh or put
to death by the king just like suddenly
escaping toward the center and if
Black's King were not on G7 but let's
say on C7 white would be completely lost
so the attack is situational it's based
on where Black's King is and we have to
make sure that it remains
firmly locked on the king side
and that's a good reason for us to keep
our dark squared Bishop alive if nothing
else that Bishop holds the king's Escape
Route via E7 under lock and key
like even if black sting Were Somehow an
F7 here it would not be able to escape
via E7 and d8 because of the presence of
this dark squared Bishop if that makes
sense so the game is over I mean we have
a lot more than we even need on the king
side but let's try to be precise because
our opponent is defending well Knight C2
okay so a couple of things to understand
here I think that there are a million
ways for us to win the game ranging from
really simple moves like even like
rookie one to C1 I think would be a good
example of a banal move that wins the
game because it adds a second attacker
and opens up a second front on the queen
side but here I would try to be a little
bit more forcing in view of our time
pressure and here I would actually start
calculating variations so Bishop F6
check comes to mind and I think is a
much better version here than it was on
the previous move here's how that goes
after Bishop F6 check black has to take
then we play e takes F6 check and in
that resulting position black has a
choice either he can take the pawn or he
can duck away to h8 if he takes the pawn
on F6 we have Checkmate in two moves we
can slide the queen over to G5 King
drops back to F7 and then Rook F3 is
literally checkmate
if after Bishop F6 Rook takes F6 ef6 the
king Ducks back to h8 I think in that
position we have a very simple move
which rather than getting too fixated on
the Checkmate just wins a bunch of
material does anybody see what move I'm
referring to and we're actually going to
reach this position assuming our
opponent doesn't take on F6 and this is
another very instructive concept within
the general realm of attacking chess
which was which is not to get too
transfixed on ending the attack with
Checkmate right this is a huge huge
reason why a lot of attacks fail is you
you get you fall in love with the
prospect of delivering Checkmate and you
don't realize that one way of concluding
a successful attack is just to like win
a bunch of material I've talked about
this a lot in like other videos and
other speedrun games and this is a great
example of that right it's very easy
here you have two minutes less than two
minutes you start calculating or like F7
maybe a queen sack on H7 all of that is
totally unnecessary maybe there is
Checkmate but I see a move which I know
for a fact ends the game on the spot
because it wins the night on C2 and then
we're gonna be up in exchange and we're
gonna have this decisive attack okay so
this isn't some sort of like
you know weak weak man's attacking move
I think this is probably even the best
move according to the engine as you'll
find and one other important observation
is that the Knight is actually pinned
not in the traditional way
but if it takes the Rook we have Queen
takes H7 Checkmate otherwise black would
have a way to give away the queen of her
two pieces and the game would continue
okay now we obviously Play Bishop takes
C2 and we kind of enter the final stage
where we just need to make a couple more
accurate moves and finish off the attack
and the most Pleasant type of attack is
one in which you actually are up
material because then you don't feel the
pressure of having to convert the attack
uh in a certain span of time so what's
the easiest way to end this game well
any time upon is moves you have to
briefly assess what squares it opens up
for your pieces there are two moves that
win on the spot the first is to complete
the Rook lifts with Rook G3 but the more
thematic move is Queen to G6
how do you see this move well you should
have been aware of this idea really for
the entirety of the game and I think
it's kind of fitting that our early
decision to put the bishop on B1 rather
than F1 or B5 bears fruit at the very
end of the game like we actually end the
game by finally being able to set up
this battery and in the event of Queen
G8 this is just made into
so a simple game a pretty
straightforward attack nothing crazy
nothing special but this is how uh this
is how to kill the French essentially
so
I will not be able to talk about like a
even 1 100th of the theory of this
variation and B about like all of the
key ideas in this structure because this
is a very complicated structure but I'll
try to give you like a general picture
of what we want to achieve with white
and what you need to study if you want
to reach a good command of of the Tariff
variation which has brought me a lot of
success
so previously in previous speedruns I
recommended the names of each variation
I still stand by it I still think it's a
great line and I'm trying to give you
like a choice
um and in this position C3 is the
traditional Advanced variation also very
good but the line that we played
previously is Knight to F3 and the basic
idea is that if black takes on D4 you
don't recapture on D4 you aim for quick
development and control over key squares
in the center you're basically trying to
keep this Pawn alive and make sure that
this Pawn seriously clamps down on
Black's development but at a higher
level this line is considered to be a
little bit dubious and if black knows
how to play against it like White's not
contending for an advantage in fact like
white is struggling for equality if
black plays this very precisely which is
why you know at 2100 plus level I like
the Tara Knight T2 so black has two main
continuations here and then there's a
couple of Sidelines the main
continuations the ones that you'll
encounter by far the most often are
Knight F6 and then the immediate Central
strike C5 and in response to C5 I can
direct you direct you to Wesley so's uh
chessable course 1e4 where I think he
has some of the best analysis of this
variation that you'll find anywhere so
if you really want to go deep and learn
the Taurus you should go to Wesley's
dressable course now as a caveat Wesley
I'm pretty sure recommends the more
traditional 92 variation which is a
great line but this is more positional
whereas I prefer to play more tactically
um so you can kind of pick and choose
from Wesley's course now as an elevator
summary of what C5 is all about here the
move I recommend is Knight G to F3
aiming for quick development and making
sure that both of your central pawns are
are covered and there's a pretty
staggering amount of theory here the
main continuation nowadays is C takes D4
uh Knight takes D4 and now Knight to C6
is considered the sort of the most
straightforward continuation here you
bring your Bishop out to B5 black
responds with Bishop D7 you play Knight
takes C6 and you reach like another very
typical kind of Pawn structure that you
have to understand and know in order to
play the Tara successfully in fact black
can play Bishop takes E6 here but more
common in recent times is Pawn take C6 I
faced this pretty recently in one of my
last tournaments the bishop drops back
to D3 and I feel like this position is
just much easier to play for white
especially if you're like a newer to
intermediate player than it is for Black
um we will skip uh the analysis of this
line and kind of leave it to the next
time that we Face the French
in this analysis I would like to focus
on Knight F6 because there's more than
enough to talk about here the sidelines
by the way are D takes E4 which is the
Rubinstein variation
um and this is a line that is favored by
a couple of French experts including
York Meyer uh the German GM who's
basically played this for his whole life
this is nothing to be afraid of again
black and fight for equality here with
like super super accurate play but for
newer players White's position is just
much much easier to play and this is not
something that is going to stop you from
playing guitar successfully and then
there's like a couple of third rate
lines like Knight C6 I think this is
called the guimard line white responds
with Knight F3 and this line can get
very tactical as well and then at some
point Bishop E7 was really popular as
well but most likely if black plays
Bishop E7 and you respond with Knight to
F3 this line is likely to transpose into
a version actually into the game
continuation like after Knight F6 you
play E5 then you play Bishop D3 and we
literally have the exact position from
the game so black can start with Bishop
E7
the only main deviation is that black
and goes C5 in this position which leads
to a fundamentally different variation
here you have to study some Theory after
Pawn takes C5 so remember that yes there
is a lot to know but all of these
positions are very difficult to play for
black and if black plays the French he
also has to know a ton and in almost any
situation where both sides are on their
own this is my central contention I
think it's much easier to play with
white if you're acquainted with you know
basic ideas and basic structures than it
is to play Black in most of these Taurus
variations all right so hopefully I'm I
haven't lost you yet
let's go with Knight F6 Knight fd7
Bishop D3 these moves are basically
automatic there is a sideline here where
black plays B6 again it's nothing to
write home about
for the purposes of this analysis we'll
stick to Knight C6 Knight gf3
so a couple of words about
uh traditional ways of playing this for
black the most important line that you
should absolutely know if you want to
play this successfully with white is the
move Queen to B6
so Queen B6 is the old Main Line it is I
think the most testing continuation at
sort of an intermediate level and the
reason for that is that white should be
okay with a pawn sacrifice here and this
is part of the appeal of playing the
Knight F3 variation to me but this is
why more positional players like to go
92 here because if black plays Queen B6
in this position who can tell me what
additional resource white has that
allows us to protect the D4 pawn and
avoid sacrificing it who can Spot the
Difference
yeah so in this position we have Knight
F3 and now we have enough Defenders on
this Pawn we have three Defenders and
three attackers but in this version if
we put the other Knight on F3 we can't
go Knight B3 because we get forked so
technically you can defend the pawn with
Queen to A4 but it should make sense to
you that like this is not in the spirit
of the variation the queen is super
awkward on this Square it's not doing
anything and this is just not how you
want to play this line
now you might say well what's the big
problem why can't we just why can't we
just take on C5 and you know if you're
familiar with with basic positional
Concepts it should make sense that
breaking up your Pawn chain like that is
uh
from a strategic standpoint very much
undesirable and what can happen is that
you end up losing the E5 Pawn without a
lot of compensation so there is a line
here where white plays Queen E2 the only
way to defend these two pawns and black
drops the queen back to C7 and it's
already very very difficult for white uh
to protect the spawn in fact the the
only move here
that allows white to keep this Pawn
under control is Knight to B3
counter-attacking the bishop black drops
the bishop back and white brings the
bishop to F4 but here black has a very
very nasty resource that is based on the
undefended nature of this bishop and
that is the move F6 very common idea in
the French and you might get excited by
the look of e takes F6 but unfortunately
this sacrifice is unsound as tempting as
it looks after King f8 black is simply
winning
and the reason black is winning is
because white has no pieces in the
attack this square is covered by the
Knight D6 is covered by the Queen White
has no follow-up to the attack literally
there's just nothing fg7 King G7 black
is like one step away from consolidating
and white can essentially reside so here
white can play in a more resilient
manner but you have to be ready to lose
the E5 pawn and that's essentially no
fun so that's the reason why you have to
be okay with sacking the pawn and the
way to do that is by Castle in kingside
so after Queen B6 the main move is to
Castle kingside black of course takes
the pawn in the vast majority of cases
blah blah blah blah take six six takes
now the knight from D2 jumps into the
game with Knight to F3 hits the queen
protects the pawn the queen moves back
to B6 this is the main line now the
modern engines have come up with a
really nice way of playing this line
with white so traditionally the main
move was Queen to A4 trying to exert
some pressure on this Knight but
recently stockfish came up with I think
a much cooler idea which is to play A3
and the idea of A3 is quite simple let's
say the black develops his Bishop with
Bishop to E7 first of all A3 discourages
black from developing the bishop to C5
because this runs right into uh B4 so
typically black develops the bishop to
E7 in the French
and now the point is that white has the
move Bishop to E3 this is an important
idea to understand now what happens if
flag plays Queen takes B2 who can tell
why is the move A3 necessary
this is like my analysis from pretty
recently so you'll get an inside
perspective of you know what I myself
play against the French
hopefully you'll like these ideas
yeah so of course you play Bishop D4 and
the queen is trapped so why was A3
necessary because it covers the B4
Square otherwise black would be able to
evacuate via B4 so in this situation
black cannot take on B2 cannot block
with a knight because of B4 and so black
must either satisfy himself with Bishop
to C5 which is in general a very
undesirable move strategically in the
French and the reason why
is that now the G5 square is uncovered
now you might be like G5 squares
uncovered why is that important well the
reason it's important is because after a
move like Bishop dd2 which by the way is
uh far from a bad move let me just pull
up my file just a moment what can you
notice in the event the black castles
King side well with the G5 Square
uncovered the Greek gift sacrifice is
now possible
after King takes H7 Knight G5 it's a
classic Rift and it's a terrible version
for black because all of his pieces are
scattered about on the queen side so
after Bishop to C5
I actually think Bishop D2 uh is the
best move and it is the best move
according to the engine
uh black has no good moves the bishop on
C5 is stuck and the Greek gift sacrifice
Works uh really really nicely in this
version
the line goes on black plays King to G6
here
white delivers a check on C2 forces
black to play out five and after ef6
King F6 I won't bore you with like the
crazy details of this uh of this line
but after Queen H7 white has a massive
attack The Rook is coming to E1 there's
a million mate threats and this is
essentially unplayable for black from a
practical standpoint okay so hopefully
that makes sense that's why Bishop C5
isn't good so black is essentially has
to resort to playing Queen back to d8
which is super passive and now rather
than trying to Checkmate black in one go
the best approach here is just to play
quiet simple positional chess you start
by playing Rook to E1 just like
solidifying or control over the over the
center
um typically black like castles King
side now it's a great idea to bring your
queen out to C2 and force a weakening
move like H6 and now the engine likes
Rook a to D1 bringing the rest of the
pieces into the center and just look at
Black's position and how hard it is to
play and one of the more beautiful ideas
is if black tries to develop his Queen
side with B6 white already has a winning
idea why did we induce the move H6 why
is that a weakening move well this is an
idea that you should be familiar with
who can tell me how white sets up an
Unstoppable threat of basically
Checkmate on the king side this is a
really really cool move really cool move
so it's not G4 because G4 weakens
White's own kingside there is a much
more effective way of exploiting this
hook not Bishop H7 Rook D4 it's a
retreating move yeah so like the move
you want to play is Bishop H6 but if you
play too quickly you don't have a
follow-up so how do we ensure that
there's a follow-up yeah Queen C1 best
move is Queen C1 because you're also
keeping an eye on the C file and if
black plays let's say Bishop B7 then
this move already works like a charm
definitely something to file away into
your like mental directory of tactical
ideas like this position is already over
black has to try F5 and uh Yuan facade
black has to take with a knight and here
I think the fastest engine Checkmate is
uh to bring the Rook up to E5 and then
over to G5 and again notice that if
black tries to escape he gets checkmated
in one move on G6
so after Queen C1 black can essentially
resign Bishop H6 is completely
Unstoppable
um the line I analyzed was Knight C5 and
even here you can play Bishop takes H6
you actually don't need the light
squared Bishop which is kind of cool it
shows you like how abundant White's
tactical ideas are
you don't need your your lightscript
Bishop because here this is plenty
plenty sufficient and one really really
pretty idea is let's say Bishop to D7
the best way to win is to go Knight G5
and then Rook G3 and Rook takes G5 is
Unstoppable if black plays F6 there's a
check and there's a mate on H3
so just one of many many lines that show
you the Tactical potential in White's
position in this line so this is
partially why I recommend the tarash
because it really helps you develop your
your Tactical abilities
uh so after Queen B6 the new move is A3
and I really think A3 poses major major
problems for black in this line of
course Knight C5 is never scary because
you can just drop the bishop back to C2
and then your knight can come out to G5
your queen to H5 this is even worse for
black and the Knight can be always
chased away with the move B4 sometimes
French players like to go like this they
go Knight C5 and A5 but here Knight to
G5
strikes at the exposed King side and if
H6 just watch how quickly the attack
turns decides if you go Queen H5 and if
black plays G6 the move should be
totally automatic too Bishop takes G6 is
like alt completely automatic
but an instructive application of the
theme I mentioned at the end of our game
uh comes in this position what do you
think is White's best move what do you
think is White's best move here what is
the winning move yeah you don't go for
mate so a lot of newer players they
might sit there and what about this
check well this check doesn't do
anything the winning move is just Knight
F7 the freaking Rook is trapped
literally The Rook is trapped we've only
sacrificed one minor piece and we've
gotten two pawns for it well I guess one
Pawn because we were a pawn Down The
Rook cannot be defended we're just gonna
be in exchange up
if black counter attacks are a big deal
we just go Rook B1 so a very very
important takeaway from this game is
that a lot of these attacks they don't
actually conclude in Checkmate they
conclude in the gain of material and if
black plays Queen C7 there's another
classic idea Knight F7 Queen F7 and
Bishop G6 pins the queen okay so I can
analyze this for several more hours but
it was important to me to demonstrate
what to do after Queen to B6 our
opponent chose the sort of second Main
Line Bishop E7 and here there's only one
other variation that I want to explore
in depth and uh once again I will reveal
some of my like deeply held opening
secrets and that is the move G5 so there
was a point at which
this line was considered to be
essentially the refutation of the Knight
F3 variation and if you're a French
player you know you should be aware of
this incredibly scary idea of of playing
G5 and what makes this idea scary is
that black just wants to go G4 there are
some versions in which like this move
literally traps the Knight but of course
the larger point is to throw the Knight
off of F3 which releases White's control
over the D4 Pawn so if white handles
this in cautiously then White's entire
Center can collapse if white plays H3
this often exacerbates the problem
because now G4 will come and potentially
open up the H file and that's the last
thing you want okay so when I face this
line for the first time about 15 years
ago I tried something interesting after
H5 I said I'm gonna stop the progress of
what Black's pawns by playing G4 and in
response to this my opponent applied one
of the most beautiful ideas that have
ever been played against me in the
French here's what happened in that game
my opponent whose name is ABI Jude Gupta
Indian Grandmaster we got this position
and let me verify that this was the
exact position we had in the game and it
was only after that game that I uh
basically like went back to the drawing
board and developed a really good system
against G5 because I got smashed
so let me double check okay it was a
slightly different position
it was it was actually this position
except Black's Bishop was still on oh
just a moment
it was a slightly different variation
but I'm pretty sure that this idea can
be applied here basically what what
black does is he plays Queen B6
now sacrificing the pawn here makes a
lot less sense because White's Pawn is
on G4 and the king is so weak so the
only thing that white can do is play
Queen A4 and here the idea still applies
my opponent in a very similar position
played the move a six
now who can tell me what the heck the
idea of this move is
the position that we actually reached
was was really really similar
it was this exact position but Black's
Bishop was still an f8 in other words
yeah Queen to A7 and B5 and it turns out
that White's Pawn on D4 collapses
because B5 is Unstoppable You're Gonna
Lose C4 and then you're gonna lose E5
and you're gonna lose the game
this is just crushing a crushing idea
and my opponent carried this idea out
and won the game so that's when I
realized that you never never never want
to meet this by playing H3 and G4
because this weakens your king side way
too much
so instead I came back and I developed
an idea that I still think is very
strong and that is the move Queen to E2
which is actually I think a brilliant a
brilliant idea it's still not a very
common move so you're still likely to
catch a lot of players uh by surprise
with with this move
now first of all let's understand what
happens if blackplay is G4 so obviously
you drop the Knight back to E1 and you
might look at this until I don't get it
doesn't this just help black collapse
our Center well the caveat is that the
G4 Pawn is now hanging and if black
takes on D4 we recapture on G4 and this
is a terrible version for black because
although black has succeeded in
essentially exploding our Center black
now has like massive fatal weaknesses on
the king side because the queen is
coming to G7
after Knight to C6 the queen literally
dives into G7 forces Rook f8 and the E5
Pawn is very easy to defend we can do it
by playing Knight D to F3 very important
to put this Knight on F3 to open up the
diagonal for your dark squared Bishop
black is busted here completely and
utterly and totally busted just look at
Black's position black can't move
typically people play Knight C5 and you
can just drop the bishop into H6 and
then take on H7 and The Rook is going to
be trapped so this is over
but here's the secondary idea of Queen
E2
let's say the black plays uh the move H5
which is what most people end up playing
against Queen E2
now what is the idea of H5 who can tell
me why what what is this move threaten
like why can't white just do anything
and this is what helps you understand
White's response to this move
so let's say white plays like a random
move like A3 so it doesn't threaten H4
it threatens G4 because now the pawn is
protected right now the pawn is
protected so if we go down this line you
can't take on G4 anymore but now we
understand the secondary idea of Queen
E2 you play the move Queen to E3 and you
use the queen to defend the D4 Pawn
typically black excitedly plays G4 and
this queen looks like a terrible piece
because it can be chased with Bishop to
G5 I've literally had this against GMS
this is already almost losing for for
black because here you pull out your
third trump card and that's the F Pawn
you play F4
and if black takes on Passat then you
play Queen takes F3 and the attack on
the F7 Pawn becomes completely and
totally decisive
and what's really pretty is that if
black for example defends the pawn that
Knight anyone can be put to use guarding
the D4 Pawn in like the most harmonious
way imaginable black has no more way to
put pressure on D4 you have a retreating
Square for the bishop so this is never
scary and white just has like long-term
massive pressure on F7 Black's position
is super cramped etc
etc so if black plays Queen to B6 once
again you can drive drive the Knight up
to C2
and now black no longer has Bishop G5
and the plan here is just to you know
push the F Bond all the way up to F5 and
break down Black's Pawn chain and
Checkmate black on the king's side so
this is my prep in a nutshell this will
win you a lot of games so you're welcome
now mostly this is directed at higher
rated players you know like 2000 plus so
if you're a newer player and you're
watching this please don't be annoyed
like just try to like extract the the
general takeaways from from these ideas
uh the last thing I'll say is that after
Queen E2 if black plays Queen to B6 if
black plays Queen to B6 then you can
already take on C5 and the difference
between this version of DC and the
version that I discouraged you from
playing earlier like for instance in the
early version of Queen B6 the pawn on E5
lacks sufficient Defenders and it's very
important when you're particularly at a
higher rated level to discern
differences between one one version of
events and another if we compare that to
the version here the pawn and E5 is now
much better defended so the move Bishop
takes C5 it no longer comes with Tempo
and what can we use this Tempo to do
well we can use this Tempo to drive the
b-pawn all the way up to B5 Force the
Knight off of C6 and in that way we can
force black to relinquish any remaining
pressure on the E5 pawn and Black's
position is completely in shambles like
this is just awful for black Knight A5
we can go Knight B3 open up the bishop
and black is collapsing on all sides
here
uh so so that's uh G5 in a nutshell
let's transition to our opponent's move
which is A5
um so A5 you can do your own research
here I think A4 is a very simple move uh
that you can play largely without too
much preparation and so that's the
reason why I played it
okay so our opponent follows up with C
takes D4 once again if black plays Queen
to B6 here then again we can already
play the move DC and we have sufficient
Resources with which we can defend the
E5 Pawn I have this over the board once
and I won that game pretty convincingly
you play Bishop C2 and if black returns
to D7 big freaking deal you can just go
rookie one and you have just enough
Defenders to make sure that this Pawn is
safely protected now let's see who paid
attention to the game continuation let's
say that in this position black castles
kingside well a great move in this
position would be the exact move that we
played in the game the exact maneuver we
could go Knight F1 and Knight G3 or we
could play this more positionally and we
could uh pay a visit to the D4 Square
which is now a really nice Outpost for
whitesnites white is better on both
sides of the board you have B5 you have
the diagonal you have attacking chances
this is a terrible version for black and
so CD is like the more natural way to
continue here hopefully everything is
making sense night before
now I'm checking reference and I see
that this position occurred over 150
times
and there was a famous game
oh crap I actually think I had it yeah I
had a very similar position against
rosenthalis but the highest rated game
in this position was Adams against
caruana from 2009 so Mickey Adams had
this with white against Fabi in 2009 and
Adams won and interestingly Adams
actually played this a lot more
positionally
um Adams or sorry carwana played Knight
before carwana played the immediate
night to B4 and in response to this move
Adams actually did Play Bishop to B5 and
he played a brilliant positional game
which you can look up on your own but
according to the engine
instead of Bishop DB5 Bishop tb1 is a
completely viable uh positional
alternative but there's a really
interesting subtlety and based on this
subtlety I actually think that castle in
kingside is a big mistake for black this
is pretty mind-expanding stuff here's
the difference
after Castle's King side rookie one
night before Bishop E1 the King has
already committed to the king side and
it's already committed to a lifetime of
misery because of our pressure on H7 but
after the immediate night before after
Bishop B1 black doesn't have to commit
to Castle in kingside and believe it or
not the king in the center is much safer
in this particular position than it
would be on the king side so by
comparison Bishop B1 is a lot less
effective here black can play B6 and if
we try to do the same thing that we did
in the game if we play rookie one Bishop
to A6 50 games in the database here and
if we play Knight F1 black can
essentially save a Tempo on Castle in
kingside and immediately go for the
queen side pressure with Rook to see it
so this has occurred many many times in
top level games
and if white plays Knight to G3 here is
the Crux of this difference black as a
resource in this position that he would
not have if the black king were already
castled kingside it's a pretty crazy
looking move but it should make a lot of
sense if you're familiar with one of the
chief drawbacks of like the Knight
placement on G3 according to the engine
white is still better after this move
but at least it keeps practical chances
for black and it is the move H7 to H5
were black castled this move would be
impossible because that would be
unprotected black plays H5 black wants
to drive this Knight out of G3 but more
importantly black wants to prevent the
knight from jumping into H5 and the top
engine move here is one that we made in
the game and that is the move rooked A1
to A3 preparing to contest the C file
with Rook C3 this has still occurred in
a game now the engine recommends G5
opening up the familiar king-sided
attack and the position is crazy like if
you analyze at the computer here the
lines are absolutely crazy it's giving
an edge to white but obviously both
sides have like ample chances here and
so that is why Michael Adams as well as
many others decided to go Bishop B5 and
then maneuvering the knight from B1 to
C3 with like a clear positional
Advantage white is still better here but
obviously with Bishop B5 white is
basically playing on the queen side
rather than on the king side but after
Castle's King side rookie won ip4 here
Bishop B1 is a no-brainer because the
king is now stuck on the king side and
we're setting up like a massive King
side attack so this is where what it
really comes down to it's these like
small subtleties these move orders and
they are what like start to decide the
game
um at this level all right it may sound
totally insignificant but I think after
Bishop B1 black is borderline lost from
a human perspective just because White's
attack is so ridiculously strong foreign
so our opponent played very sensibly
like Knight B8 makes perfect sense
we played Knight F1 completing the
standard maneuver the engine eval here
is already plus two and a half just
because black has no play on The Queen
side whereas we are completely in
position for a decisive King side attack
and there is still a game in the
database here black was 2351 and white
was 26.39 Ukrainian Grandmaster so in
that game blackplayed the miserable move
G6
oh this is sexy and white missed the top
engine move which is still to play
Knight H5 and if black takes Knight to
G5 oh look at this bishop takes G5 you
sack two nights in a row now you play
Queen takes H5
you hit the bishop hit the pawn black
has to go here and now who can find the
brilliant winning move you already know
this idea it's time to apply it white to
play and win you know chess is just
amazing it's a quiet move it's Rook to
A3 time to involve The Rook now what
does Rook A3 do in this exact situation
well let's say black continues chomping
on the Pawns well you just go Rook G3
and black just doesn't have sufficient
defensive forces to hold up the king
side the threat is Queen takes H6 as
well as Bishop takes G5 the game is over
that's it
this would have been the fastest way to
win if black does not take the Knight on
H5 if black does not take the Knight on
H5 then um well then we win by either
sticking the Knight on F6 or playing
Bishop to H6 black has no moves here so
let's say black makes a waiting move
Bishop D7 again the engine likes to
involve The Rook Rook to A3 Rook to C8
for example
and now H4 is actually a great move
setting up a stronghold on G5 for the
other night so we literally just play
with this Knight hanging and the moment
black takes we apply our standard idea
with Knight to G5
just to show you the attacking potential
that White's pieces uh possess here I
think our opponent played uh a better
defensive move than the 2300 that did I
think G6 is just essentially a losing
move and uh
yeah so H4 is not mandatory but I wanted
to play this move because it illustrates
uh White's attacking potential
so in response to Bishop takes H4 I
think the simplest thing to do
uh would be to play Knight H5 just
sticking the Knight on like the ideal
attacking square and setting up the
threat of Knight takes G7 as well as
Rook to A3 so the engine line here is G6
we just play Knight takes H4 Queen H4 we
give a check on F6 and we win the game
because the bishop hangs and we can also
simply trap the queen with a move like
G3
um or the top engine move is Rook to A3
again lifting The Rook up to H3 and here
we have this beautiful move just winning
everything because this is Checkmate so
in response to Knight H5 G6 is literally
never possible
so let's say black withdraws the bishop
back to E7 well you will never guess
what the top engine move is here right
once you're familiar with the ideas you
can apply them over and over and over
again and who would have known that A4
is a move played not just to prevent
black from playing A4 but also to open
up the pathway for The Rook to join the
attack via A3 white plays Rook A3 black
has no moves again let's say that black
just continues accumulating on the king
side bang night G7
King G7 and now a very common follow-up
is to play
um either Knight H2 and open up the
pathway for the queen or just drive the
queen up to H6 with a completely
decisive attack
check let's say that the king tries to
run to the center
we just go Knight G5 check we take back
with the bishop and it's very obvious
where this is going and not in a
favorable direction for black queen to
B6 Queen H5 check
um and Rook G3 Etc this is easily easily
winning just Rook H3 and black has no
pieces on the king side
so one of the sub themes of this game is
like not all attacks are the same and
when you hear the word attack you often
associated with like a lightning series
of moves where every move has to be a
sacrifice many times when you're
attacking you can afford to play Slowly
right because black has nothing going
for him on the other side of the board
so a lot of attacks have to be conducted
in this very slow or relatively slow and
deliberate way and the build up to the
sacrifice is the stage of attack that's
not talked about enough right when
you're solving exercises or you're
reading books they usually talk about
the final stage that's like the stage
which begins with this move but the
stage that's not talked about enough is
the one that involves moves like H4 and
Knight H5 and Rook A3 remember that
those build up moves are an integral
part of every attack particularly
attacks that involve this many moving
parts so our opponent played F6 which I
think relatively is maybe even the best
resource
we take on F6 and now a critical part of
the game where we transition from
attacking play to positional play with
Bishop to G5
so that's a long speech but hopefully
this helps you understand how White's
attack actually works
and once again in response to Bishop
takes hg5 we have the Greek gift
sacrifice so notice how we're like
seamlessly weaving between positional
play and tactical play based on what
black is doing so if Bishop G5 we
deliver a game-winning tactic with
Bishop H7 our opponent played Queen C7
and here we continue playing
positionally with Rook to A3 our goal to
secure complete control of the E5 Square
um now if blackhead played H6 and tried
to force things yeah we would have taken
on F6
and then we could have thrown in the
move net H5 because it doesn't hurt
and then we could have continued uh by
dominating the E5 square with 95. and
the attack flows naturally now we stick
a rook on E5 the other Rook can come
into G3 and we can kind of go back to
deciding the game via uh via attack
so H6 is never scary our opponent
decided to keep the tension and the rest
of the game I think is pretty much
natural we go rookie three
I think the engine always finds ways
that like the defending side can survive
for longer but hopefully the course of
the game was able to show you just how
difficult it is for for black to play a
position like this
our opponent play Queen D6 and now we
found the perfect opportunity to play
Knight H5
our opponent played King h8 and now the
other Knight comes into E5 and already
the game is over because once again if
95 then we play D5 if black takes the
bishop on G5 then the open H file only
serves to further illustrate the
hopelessness of Black's position
in response to Knight takes E5 we can
again switch from positional to tactical
gear we can take with the pawn
voluntarily
and the reason is to Garner a Tempo that
we can use to stick the Knight on F6
and just look at this gf6 simply ef6
pre-moving Queen H5 and the game is over
just you know just look at Black's
pathetic King Rook F7 Queen H5 Rook f8
G6 is I think a simple way to end the
game so that's another one of the sub
themes of this game which is like not
assuming that you're playing with one
mode right you're not always playing
positionally or tactically you could
basically be doing both at the same time
and you're deciding on a mode based on
how your opponent is reacting but here
we're harnessing both our positional
advantages like IE our control over the
key Central Square as well as our
preponderance of pieces on the king side
and this kind of play is you know
incredibly incredibly powerful and we
conclude the game with a simple
sacrifice Knight takes G7 followed by
Queen H5 and this is already forced mate
according to the engine the fastest mate
would have been Queen H6 check and now
Bishop F6 but who cares like this
technically is the engine way to mate
but I think we we found a completely
satisfactory
uh way to win the game there was there
was no doubt about the result
but according to the engine Queen H6
Jack and Bishop F6 is fastest because
here Rook G3 is Main and if black gives
away The Rook then we play EF
I calculated to this position and forgot
that we have a check on G3 followed by
Rook G7 and this is just made on the
spot so this would be uh the fastest way
to win the game but we threw in the
immediate check and the only important
line here was uh to understand that King
takes F6 gets checkmated with Queen cg5
again notice the power of the Pawn on H4
followed by Rook to F3 and that's
another cool takeaway from this game I
think most people when they think about
the use of Pawns in attacking they think
of like Pawn storms right so when you
see the move H4 is a less experienced
player you might think that the only
idea is just to run the pawn up to H6
and to Shadow Black's Pawn formation and
that is a viable use of Pawns and
attacking but there is a second use
which is to basically Advance pawns and
use them as pedestals on which you can
put your pieces like the pawn can be a
very powerful supporting supporting
piece uh which can open doors for your
minor pieces to jump into squares that
they otherwise couldn't access and
that's ultimately what ended up
happening in the game or what could have
ended up happening if blackheads played
King takes F6
as it stood like we just play Rook C3
then we take the Knight and then we mate
with Queen to G6 or a platform is a
better
is a better term I think so ins 90 asks
why not the immediate night or Rook C3
after uh Knight C2 well because that
blunders the pawn in F2 and then the
Rook on E1 this would be the best way to
complicate the game white is still
winning after Bishop takes C2 this just
illustrates how bad it is for black you
can literally blunder this Pawn with
check and then the rook and you're still
winning but why why allow any of that
right
also the E5 Pawn a platform for the
bishop to jump into F6 hopefully you
know that wasn't too rambly just as a
quick summary
we didn't talk much about the other
options in this position or for black
the main one is C5 and I have a feeling
that we're still going to face this uh
in a later game in the speed run here we
focused on the second main line
now there are some Sidelines along the
way that we didn't talk about so I
showed you some of my preparation after
Queen cp6 the bottom line is that you
are ready and willing to sacrifice the
pawn on T4 and the second line we
focused on is this very sharp line with
uh G5 and in response to G5 Queen E2 is
a very very powerful uh weapon to have
up your sleeve of course these this
merely scratches the surface like at one
point G6 was considered to be uh the
best move in the position and I still
believe that G6 is probably Black's best
bet to get uh Dynamic equality this is
something we'll leave for a separate
analysis also interesting is the
immediate A5 uh also a line that was
very very popular at some point but most
intermediate players I think are still
going to face Bishop E7 most of the time
and in this position we also didn't talk
about Castle's King side to which you
respond rookie one and again this idea
Knight F1 Knight G3 is kind of White's
main follow-up but hopefully you found
the
analysis to be
semi-enlightening and that concludes the
speedrun game for today if you're
watching on YouTube you can see how much
more complicated the games are becoming
it's becoming harder for me to explain
everything concisely and hopefully I'm
doing like a decent job of it but yeah
like the games are becoming a lot more
variation heavy there's a lot more
Concepts involved but that's called
chest progression right that's why it's
hard to improve because to win at this
level you need to have
command of like many many different
concepts that you display every single
game from opening Theory knowledge to
knowledge of when to sacrifice to
knowledge of how to play simultaneously
attacking chess while also exploiting
positional factors that's just part of
the process of Chess Improvement and I'm
just doing my best to highlight some of
these skills and to show you how I'm
able to apply them uh consistently to to
win games
so on that note we're gonna end for
today folks I'm exhausted I am going to
pass the stream off to whom am I going
to pass it off that's the big question
I'm going to pass it off to zephcat been
a while since we rated zephcat
let's do that now thank you everybody
for hanging out and for uh
paying attention during the speed runs
it really really helps to have a captive
audience hope you enjoyed the chess
thanks again for all the support in the
subs for those who donated one quick
note if you're new to this channel you
like what I do you want to support me
um easiest way to do that is to
subscribe on my YouTube channel the goal
is to reach 500k Subs by the end of 2023
it's not gonna happen but the best
chance is for people to subscribe if you
like my content and you want uh more of
the same so thanks everybody
thank you
[Music]